- Atteint d'un cancer avancé
du côlon, Thomas Hartle
cherch m m m moyen d'atténuer
son anxiété liée
à son diagnostic et
à la perspective de la mort.
En 2020, il a reçu une rare
exemption d'Ottawa lui
tatatatant de suivre
une thérapie par psilocybine,
des champignons magiques.
Les effets ont été immenses,
confie-t-il.
Cette année il a pu renouveler
l'expérience, cette fois grâce
à un changement
de réglementation.
Depuis janvier, Santé C
permet aux médecins dans
le cadre du Programme d'accès
spécial de demander à prescrire
des drogues psychédéliques
à un patient, sous strictes
conditions et supervision.
En six mois, plus
d'une trentaine de demandes
ont été reçues.
Une avancée pour ce médecin,
mais il souligne que
le processus demeure
laborieux et limité.
"Il faut des incitatifs
pour que les gens se soignent
dans un espace sûr, dit-il,
pour éviter qu'ils risquent
l'automédication."
Pour l'instant, avant
d'envisager d'autres
changements, Santé Canada
attend de pouvoir s'appuyer
sur plus d'études.
"nnnnnnnne démarche
scientifique est primordiale",
note ce chercheur.
Il s'apprête justement à lancer
des essais cliniques sur
le microdosage de psilocybine.
Le développement de ce domaine
commence aussi en même temps
à susciter l'intérêt
d'investisseurs, constate
cette avocate, des compagnies
prêtes à mettre de l'argent
dans la recherche ou de futurs
centres de traitement.
"Au dernier décompte, dit-ellee
sociétés inscrites à la bourse."
Le début peut-être
d'une certaine renaissance
pour ces substances.
Ici Camille Gris-Roy,
Radio-Canada, Toronto